it was an obvious exercise in dot
connecting when Mel Tucker left Colorado
to go to Michigan State Colorado as if a
can see Eric the enemy is a coach he's
Colorado's all-time leading rusher
Colorado has reached out reportedly
twice now to be enemy who is according
to Adam Schefter of ESPN doing his due
diligence when it comes to possibly
becoming the head coach at Colorado I I
would be stunned if he goes and I think
he's just being nice and he's being
respectful and it's his former school
and he doesn't want to just hang up the
phone on them Shareen but he's in the
pipeline to be an NFL head coach I think
if you go coach at Colorado which has
become a stepping stone school for
Michigan State apparently you step out
of the pipeline to be an NFL head coach
I don't think that Eric Bana me stays at
the start at the top of the list of NFL
coaching candidates for 2021 if he
leaves the Chiefs now and goes to
Colorado which makes me convinced he's
not gonna leave well do we know that
Eric the enemy wants to become an NFL
head coach more than a college head
coach I don't know that I'm assuming
that but I don't know that for sure and
when your alma mater calls you have to
go back and at least listen and consider
it and maybe he's gotten to the point to
where he just says look I've been passed
over and passed over and passed over I'm
tired of this I'm gonna go be a head
coach whether it's for one year or five
years or ten years or a lifetime maybe
he's reached that point again though I
would be surprised if he took this job
he he should be now I thought he would
get a head coaching job in this hiring
cycle and he didn't but he should get
one in 2021 he should have gotten one in
2020 he didn't he should get one in 2021
so if he wants to become an NFL head
coach the route to that is to stay in
Kansas City not to go to Colorado but if
he just wants to become a head coach
going back to your alma mater makes a
whole lot of sense if you know if if the
NFL is not calling for you and that is
not something that you definitely want
to do you just want to be a head coach
the idea that he could get exasperated
at some point by being passed over for
NFL head coaching
I get that but it's only been two cycles
that he's been an offensive coordinator
and then in that mix and in that
discussion for potential head coaching
opportunities so I think his ship will
come in at the NFL level at some point
and the other aspect and very basic
reality is this I'm not leaving the side
of Patrick mahomes no way nohow
I already got a Super Bowl ring from the
experience I may get a second one and
the one thing I want to know I want to
have that heart-to-heart with Andy Reid
how long do you plan on coaching I'm
trying to do a I'm trying to get my my
information is there can you can you
shed some light are you looking at five
years are you looking at 10 years it's
fine you stay over long you want I just
want to know so I can make my plans and
you know if Andy Reid if there's any
chance that you know he's gonna retire
at 65 that's a factor for me maybe I
just hang around here maybe I say no to
these other head coaching opportunities
college and pro because if there's a
chance to be Patrick mahomes head coach
for five to ten years that's a hell of a
lot better than coaching anywhere else
don't you think Eric the enemy deserved
a head coaching job in this cycle that
he that he's done enough and he was a
great candidate for all these team I
mean I think he should have gotten one
in this cycle when I look at the coaches
who were hired he should have been one
of those guys
well I and Sims and I've talked about
this
I don't think Kevin Stefanski should
have been hired by the Browns I don't
think Kevin Stefanski has done enough in
a one-year and two or three games as an
offensive coordinator to make me think
he's a can't-miss surefire deserving
head coaching candidate especially
because the best thing about the Vikings
offense this year was Gary Kubiak not
Kevin Stefanski and the Gary Kubiak is
the guy that Mike Zimmer singled out and
said Kubiak is the best decision I've
made since becoming head coach of the
Vikings not Stefanski so at a minimum he
should be the head coach to the Browns
now some of these other jobs I mean Joe
judge versus Eric the enemy I you could
say be enemy but you know the I think
then the challenge is no way didn't help
keep Doug Peterson or Matt naggy from
becoming head coaches but the idea that
you're the offensive coordinator
for an offensive mastermind it makes it
harder to stand out look Pete
Carmichael's been Sean Payton's
offensive coordinator all these years
his name never gets mentioned for head
coaching jobs anywhere the fact that
Andy Reid has created this coaching tree
of offensive guys when he's an offensive
guy is kind of remarkable but I think at
a minimum assuring to finally answer
your question he should be the head
coach the Browns right now I agreed with
that I think he should be there with the
Browns and he's not and if he waits he
will be somewhere in 2021 for sure if
not Colorado in 2020 we'll see how it
plays out another out pft live still
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports